Sophie scott is a British neuroscientist
and senior fellow at University College
London,
research in the neuroscience of voices,
speech and laughter.
She's known for our public engagement
work,
including performing standup comedy and
was featured in BBC radio four program,
the life scientific.
Her research investigates the neural
basis for vocal communication,
how our brains process the information,
speech and voices,
and how our brains control the
production of our voice.
It's made me really self conscious of my
voice that has now sophie professor.
Thank you,
Professor Sophie.
Sophie,
professor,
thank you for professor coming here and
doing this interview with me.
I'm very grateful.
Thank you very much for inviting me.
I saw you on Jimmy Carr.
I'm a fan and indeed friend of Jimmy's
and he'd done a horizon where he talked
about the neuro,
the neurology of laughter.
Can you just summarize what you're doing
on that show because it will help me to
do a show with you now.
Uh,
they came to me because I'm one of the
few people researching laughter in the
UK.
If you go onto,
um,
the major database of science papers and
you do a search on emotion expression of
fear,
you get back over 4,000
published papers on fear and if you do a
search on emotion expression,
laughter,
you get back 150 papers there,
just no papers in it,
did no research going on into it.
And so I was lucky that meant that they
will know what else they could ask about
how,
you know,
how and why we laugh.
Um,
and that's something I've been looking.
I've been looking at it from a
perspective of how,
how we communicate with each other.
And I got interested in positive
emotions in communication.
And as soon as you start doing that,
you find that laughter is just weird.
It's everywhere.
It's continuously founding conversation.
People did much,
much more than they think they do.
And we coordinate it really nicely in
conversation.
And interestingly,
if you ask people about laughter,
those what makes you love when you love,
they'll talk about jokes and comedy and
humor,
but actually out in the wild,
most laughter is just happening in
conversations and people aren't laughing
at jokes.
Let me do laugh at jokes and comedy.
People are laughing to show that they
know each other and like each other and
understand each other.
Oh,
you mean the social wild ocelot humans,
monkey,
human,
primate people.
Exactly.
So like,
yeah,
I do notice that.
I listened now for that sound.
And one of the aspects of laughter,
humor,
comedy and communication I'm interested
in is the political discourse.
John cleese has it.
Brilliant thing.
I wonder if you're aware about a serious
and solemnity seriousness and solemnity.
He said like,
people prohibit the use of humor in
particular areas of the public sphere
because of its potency and its ability
to disrupt.
And I've always found it interesting
that with the emergence of political
figures like Nigel Farrage,
Boris Johnson and date Donald Trump,
people that are sort of used a different
type of rhetoric,
uh,
kind of accessibility and a kind of
humor.
But of course,
humor has always been a part of the
political discourse,
if you know,
they,
they make jokes all the time in
parliament and in Congress.
They use humor to make people like them.
And I always think the,
um,
some of the idioms around comedy or
interesting make people laugh is a form
of control.
What have you got to add to that
bloating?
Well,
no,
I think you're right.
It's an incredibly nuanced behavior in
adulthood and it,
it's interesting to think about its
roots because its roots lie in play and
play behavior.
That's what happened when baby's first
laugh.
When the parents take a little more
picky with people,
you could move with them and that all
came out wrong.
Play peekaboo with them.
Then that's a,
it's a response to a playfulness.
There's no joke there.
There's no bigger structure.
It's a,
you know,
I understand you're engaging with me in
this fun way.
And it's absolutely basic to pro or
primates.
Mammals.
It's a map that's a mammal behavior
play.
We understand that there are strata of
behavior.
So there's one by via,
wherever you.
If I said I'm very offended by what
you've just said on this podcast,
you would go,
you would recognize that as,
oh my God,
this is serious.
And then if I thought really,
you're absolutely gorgeous,
then there's sort of a sense of relief.
Yeah.
So lack of.
It's the acknowledgement that there are
frequencies you saying and these
frequencies are vocally expressed,
but they're real logically understood.
Another demonstrable.
Is it like something that's happening in
play that neurologically that is not
present in serious in the communication?
That's a good question.
And I don't know.
I don't know if I can give you an
equally good answer.
We know that,
um,
play is incredibly important to mammals
as they're developing all mammals play.
And even if you grow up to be a
completely a Social Predator mammal,
then you will see that would be like a
tiger,
a,
yeah,
an old big cats.
Um,
or even now I'm going to explain this
really badly paid.
Even if you'll grow up to be a very
frightening mammal.
It never plays a,
um,
well it big cats.
I'm auteurs and that's not true.
What I'm doing this very badly.
Gorgeous.
Now please tell us what is it?
Good.
What is a good a printer that's not
playful.
What about that gorgeous gorilla with
night eyes?
I saw her on Gogglebox.
Well,
gorillas are a good example of they're
not predators.
They're vegetarians,
but they are.
They continue to play throughout their
lifetime like humans do.
Like artists do,
like dogs do.
Most mammals play in juvenile period and
that's when they're learning.
We've got these massive brains.
We have this extended period of being
juveniles when we're training those big
brains up and this is all mammals and we
we learned mostly play,
not entirely,
but that's one of the structures and
then in adulthood most mammals stop and
a handful carry on like our dogs auteurs
other primates doing this playful
behavior and what you find is that a
behavior like laughter starts having a
relatively simple role.
It's social bonding,
it's playfulness,
and then as we get older it becomes more
and more complex tool.
By the time you were an adult and you're
hearing laughter,
it's almost like a hall of mirrors of
interpretation.
Somebody.
It could be laughing because there
helplessly laughing.
There could be laughing because they're
embarrassed because they're frightened
because they're trying to cover up being
angry because they trying to make
somebody like them because they're in
pain.
Studied all these different reasons why
laughter starts to appear around you and
when you're in an interaction with
somebody,
you're normally pretty good,
normally pretty good at reading that.
It's often when you're inhale,
after going on,
it's part of something that has maybe
nothing to do that.
Okay,
what's.
What are they laughing?
Listen to them laughing and it seems
those pigs,
they didn't even pigs.
What do they love?
What's going on?
Well,
actually even worse,
you think they're laughing at you.
You know,
because that's another thing.
Am I included in this lover and my
explanation?
The love.
So it's,
it's.
You're always thinking about it.
It's always meaningful.
Even if it's got apparently nothing to
do with you,
you will pay some attention to laughter
and try and work out what's going on
because it is such a meaningful
behavior.
It's interesting that laughter is vocal
but nonverbal.
That is sort of a sort of super
linguistic is beyond language life,
it's what you look to to communicate in
situations where language isn't of use
to you to try to connect to people for
it after.
Absolutely,
and in this it sits with a set of things
called non verbal emotional expressions
which are more like animal calls and
they are like speech.
So when I'm talking to you now I'm doing
something no other no other animal can
do in nature I you,
we are.
When we talk to each other,
produce this incredible sound that
starts down at a rib cage and we're
making sounds at our voice box of them
is shaped that with our tongue and our
lips and our jaw and that's.
This gives us this sound literally
unparalleled in nature and then when we
are in a really pretty extreme emotional
state,
we don't bother with that at all and we
just squeeze the air out and we make
screams and grunts and sounds all
laughter and they're really much more
basic sounds.
I listen now sometimes when I'm talking
to people to hear the sort of noises
they make.
There aren't words like a sentence
paragraph,
what are you doing?
Just up to there when he made that
little grown.
It's weird,
isn't it?
It is odd and I know we signaling,
signaling,
glean availability,
power status,
what's going on,
professor?
There's that.
There's a rather unfortunately named
term called back channeling,
which means,
Oh yes,
I know it fairly well.
I'm afraid.
I began back channeling on my 17th
birthday,
never called again.
What it means is people show that their
listing,
so they tend to make little noises they
might make loves,
but they also make all sorts of noises
just like I'm here and I'm engaged with
you.
He's like,
icontact.
I'm using it to indicate that I'm
listening.
I might also use it to indicate I'm
ready to speak to.
Also,
you know,
we,
we don't sit and receive messages and
then start emitting them at somebody
else.
We we speak to be understood and we
listened to show that we're following
and that's making funny noises can be
part of that.
It's extraordinary what's happening
beyond the understood signifiers within
language.
Is it,
you know,
whenever you hear that thing of like,
oh,
90 percent of communication is
nonverbal,
how can it be if someone's doing a
speech for a guy and we're going to be
raising taxes by this amount.
You're not freaking my attempt.
Like those eyebrows you have.
So thinking the information,
what's going across,
isn't it?
It definitely is,
but it's,
it's interesting that as soon as you
have a person talking to you,
there is never just the words.
There's always a voice.
Yes.
And you do get a lot of other
information from that voice.
Um,
I was thinking about this this morning.
I was listening to the,
the sex pistols and that,
you know,
God save the Queen and that came out.
Everyone's like,
Oh God,
this is so shocking.
And they keep going,
oh no,
we love the queen.
And I don't think they might.
Yeah,
that's a loaded voice.
Exactly.
And that I was just,
you know,
pre pubescent at that time it seemed
incredibly threatening because they
definitely pretty certainly don't have
the queen at all.
And it was all coming from how it's
phrased and how it's being used in all
the sound that's contributing to the
noise that they're making.
So I came into this area working on
speech.
I thought I worked on language.
That was what I would tell people.
I did languages well eat.
But even even that was made when I was
started scanning brains and you could
find all these brain areas that we're
responding to,
uh,
the words that you understand and all
the linguistic stuff there.
But you also got all these other brain
areas that don't care at all about
words,
but they absolutely care about someone
saying it.
And of course they're always there if
there's someone speaking,
there's a voice.
And as soon as there's a voice,
as another channel of information that
you are processing really strongly and
the brain cares at least as much about
that as it does about the words in terms
of activation.
Because if I think about this,
if you were to suddenly be turned into
an austere mail from like sort of the
Ukraine,
who was just saying the exact same
content to me in this world,
Russell,
of course love to bond.
I think having a totally different
experience.
Of course there's all sorts of physical
and aesthetic data,
but that,
that what is contained in the voice is
communicating in a powerful way.
So the reason that I didn't understand,
oh,
90 percent of information is nonverbal.
It's because I'm precisely unaware of
the way I'm being affected by sound
because we don't know how to categorize
it.
I mean it's language is about what's
being said.
It's about distinction.
I'm saying this and not this and it's
easy to categorize and understand less
easy,
I suppose,
as these aspects of communication that
are non not vocabulary.
You're super linguistic.
Absolutely.
They don't directly influence what your.
The words necessarily that you're saying
all the can interact with it,
but as soon as you,
soon as you hear a voice,
you've got a person,
you've got a good idea at agenda,
you've got a good shot is an age,
socioeconomic status,
geographical origins,
mood health.
That's very empowering and it's also
aspirational.
People talk in a way that they want
people to see them as like when I've
been on the phone to my mum,
I taught like my mum for about half an
hour afterwards and you know,
loved my mom,
didn't really want to sound like it,
but I'm showing all this stuff about our
relationship.
As soon as I started talking to her and
all of us do that all the time.
I'm talking differently to you now
because I'm trying
to project a particular.
What is it?
World?
I'm hoping it's competent scientists.
I'm hoping I'm probably landing on it so
much more.
Sophie Scott and so much more,
um,
what we're projecting onto the world and
the way that we want to be received and
he's sort of laughter somehow a
supplement to that or a disruption to
that.
I think it's,
it can be both,
so a lot of the time it's something that
you're actively using to try and effect
interaction.
So here's an example.
I was on the cheap last week and not
particularly full tube coming away from
Heathrow and there was a suitcase with
no one anywhere near and I suddenly
realized I was unattended suitcase so
and there were empty seats by it.
So the,
how many happy,
you know,
they all know I'm gonna have to say
something so.
Okay.
Right.
Excuse me,
Dan,
you know,
everyone,
people I'm with going,
oh,
she's going to say,
excuse me,
is this anybody suitcase?
And there's one right at the other end
of the character goes,
Oh yes,
it's mine.
And she came there and I was,
she was saying,
oh sorry,
I didn't realize that become available.
And I was going,
oh,
don't worry.
We were both laughing to kind of go,
this is okay,
so I'm not telling you off.
No one's crossed with you.
It's all right here.
Signaling to each other.
This is cool.
This is absolutely.
We all have the external reference that
an unattended bag could mean death and
it's in that context.
I mean I have seen people get really
told off or unattended luggage so you
know,
we're both trying to make it clear we're
not doing that and she's also very
sorry,
but in fact that is a really nuanced use
of laughter that people that that was
not helpless.
Laughter.
I was not in any sense of mused entirely
to try and make it better,
less threatening.
It was an expression of a kind of
relief.
Of course,
right?
They're sort of like,
because there's the process.
Of course,
if you go now this isn't a terrorist
attack on the tube,
but also that your social interaction
has not failed.
It has not been misinterpreted that
you've successfully communicated,
Oh,
I'm another concerned person.
Yeah,
we're all good here.
And if people,
if that goes wrong,
of course love to can suddenly be really
inappropriate and you do encounter
situations where people will be like,
what?
You think?
This is a joke.
You're laughing at me.
I hate that.
Like in Goodfellas or it's an awful
moment.
It's that.
It makes your blood run cold.
It does happen quite a lot.
That's basically a continuum in my life
ever suffered.
Let the rhythm section of my life is
people going,
what?
You're trying to be funny mate.
What's that then?
And it's awful.
It's interesting that it actually in the
rhetoric of a violent conflict and we
try them and expert like the sort of
like what you're trying to be funny.
Do you think you're funny that that's
sort of like a bit of language that
comes up a lot,
isn't it?
Yep.
Because it's undercutting,
I suppose.
Of course humor is disrupting their.
Say there's a standard frequency of like
the Banal exchange of information with
whatever independent personal
inflections you have as your default.
Then humor is subverting that.
Oh right.
I'm in here too.
Good to introduce some sort of jackets,
spikes all of this.
And then another person for power can
go,
no,
this isn't funny,
or I don't like that feeling at all.
I've made myself nervous just talking
about it.
Quite a lot of the behaviors that we do.
Um,
light,
laughter and yawning,
blinking,
contagious.
Most of the blinks you do,
you don't need to do your blinks.
Blinks were blinking our lives away.
Pointlessly thing.
If you watch a baby,
they don't.
They don't do this because we should.
We learn contagious behaviors.
We learn to pick them up from people and
laughed is a really big one to watch my
baby.
I do watch her.
She don't blink very much.
He's actually bloody exhausting.
She won't have any blinking,
but with laughter with the baby,
I noticed that.
Well,
yeah.
Well if I got turned around like that
and stuff,
she loves all that.
Yeah.
She loves sort of monster play and
biting and all that.
Not Hard.
Not they're not aggressive,
but it seems like that there is a
function and it's.
And when I think about what is my
impetus to initiate that behavior,
is it recognizing she doesn't yet have
language,
but I want to feel bonded to her and I
want to feel closeness to her and I want
to touch her and staff so that place
seven,
the function of a,
of reiterating and compounding our
connection.
Absolutely.
Isn't this very interesting.
It is quite striking that we laughed so
early.
You know,
we,
we can cry pretty soon as soon as we're
born.
You know,
humans are born about three months too
soon because of our massive heads and
then around the time we would be born we
start laughing,
so probably it should have been there
right from the outset and then ages
later we start making other sounds and
it's very interesting that the second
thing that comes in is this incredibly
potent positive vocalization because
babies don't catch laughs from adults,
but the adults love when the babies love
and you start teaching them about it
starts becoming an interaction and
there's very nice evidence that well
before babies are linguistic in any
sense that they can speak at all.
They're probably understanding a lot,
but they can't do anything vocal.
They will pay attention to.
Their parents laughed and they will
start doing things to make their parents
laugh.
Precisely because of this communicative
linkedin is giving in this interaction
that it gives you so long before you're
having conversations.
Babies are using laughter as actively as
you're using love to now to,
to drive interactions with you
more efficiently.
In the case of my baby and me,
she's a very funny trial.
So like what I'm thinking then is that
there is power in laughter,
there is power in laughter as a form of
communication and barefoot comedy.
There is power in it.
So like I wanted to.
One of the things we've done some pre
production here and that's very rare for
us.
We've got a like examples of politicians
using humor and uh,
I wonder if we can analyze this is part
of our podcast because we are
professionals now.
Cenk or you'll have to make sure that we
can hear it.
Maybe you can play into that mic.
What Mike is that,
that you're on Mike,
for what?
That,
what's that one?
Gower.
Does that make it go on?
You want to play in there?
But will we actually able to hear that
in the room?
I wonder even growing.
They're just.
So the first one is the first person
that's using humor is just sort of a
comedy staple of the British political
world.
It's Boris Johnson using humans to
communicate 14 to try and bikes to
Holland boomerangs to Australia sands
exports of,
but we do still export wine to Italy and
I'm delighted to say Nigel farage to
America now.
Boris Johnson,
I think is a really good example because
I think he's one of the things that
human does.
Izzy,
I think signals and awareness of another
seam of communication.
Like if you're like,
if you're using comedy,
you're sort of saying like,
I know that on one level we're having
this discourse like eat there.
Boris Johnson is given a speech in some
sort of context like business and
economics species to the next selling
sand to the Arabs,
which is a racist trope actually,
but he found a way of have taken out the
most obvious racism and making a dog
whistle racism.
One of his great skills actually Boris
Johnson and uh,
but it's like he's being deliberately
humorous.
What do you think Boris Johnson is doing
there?
If I'm absolutely honest,
I think Boris Johnson is very carefully
cultivated a kind of clownish persona to
cover up a tremendously powerfully
interested in success politician.
He's there was a very interesting essay
by Jonathan Coe pointing out that Doris
Johnson didn't used to be funny.
He used to be just the Pashto in the
nineties.
It was this,
here's this,
another privileged individual from
Eaton.
And he was on,
have I got news for,
you know,
I remember that.
And the first time he was on,
um,
in his lap,
kept having a go at him about a phone
call he'd had with the journalists could
turn to someone called diaries.
Gfi was trying to get the details out of
Johnson and Johnson doesn't get mad with
very well and his just would not come by
way from.
It kept coming back to Katelyn back to.
And in the end I think Paul Martin
[inaudible] you got a bit bored,
made a joke about it and that was funny
and the audience laughed and it somehow
simultaneously got Boris Johnson off the
hook and somehow the laughter stuck to
him not to pull them out.
And He'd actually made the joke that was
like Batman when Batman was in that cave
of bat and became Batman.
I'm funny,
man,
if I'm funny,
I don't ever have to reveal my mackie
eventually in self interest and a huge
political ambitions.
I can just laugh my way to the top or at
least to the middle and that certainly
what Jonathan Co makes quite a good
argument for that which I think contains
a lot of weight and it certainly needs.
It points out that the laughter kind of
surrounding Boris Johnson,
he understands very well.
He knows it's not a sign that people are
thinking deeply about his intentions
kind of.
It becomes easy to teach them as a joke
and then he can use to a certain extent
and it's a double edge sword,
but you are licensed to do different
things.
If people treat you as funny and that
works for you and it can work against
you and he's been very good at making it
work for him.
He really has because they're so things
like,
you know,
those allegations about his private life
that blokey sort of lost his way out of
sort of lots of contentious decisions
made while mayor fancy sort of like he's
reverse or this brexit stuff and now
he's repositioning as sort of an attack
dog for the conservatives in this
election with that.
So if I noticed,
he said that he's got beautiful.
I mean he's obviously incredibly
intelligent man,
brilliantly inexpensively educated man
and when he sort of contrived an insult
like mutton headed mug one lot,
I think that's beautiful.
Bit of language is a really,
really good attack.
And like all good comedies,
it's got a sort of a specific revelation
and a specific intent is a cervic and
lacerating piece of language that.
And,
and I,
I feel that when he's doing that stuff
that there's a great power in it.
Like,
you know,
I don't think we've seen the summit of
Boris Johnson's Korea and luck on what's
happening across the water is an
indication that there's this type of
charm and charisma is a useful way of
attaining power.
Django,
can we put up an American one now just
for the purposes of keeping some balance
and I'll put that mic up again.
So this is what this is this Donald
Trump being funny.
Obama or trump or Obama?
He was.
Well funny.
He's good because he's charismatic as
all hell.
He's good looking.
I liked Bernie.
Bernie's and guy.
Apparently some folks really want to say
a pot smoking socialist in the White
House.
We could get a third Obama term after
it.
So Nice.
Nice little joke there.
I mean that.
That's how.
I mean that's a scripted joke.
Obviously.
It's a very sort of clear where it's
going.
Once he says pot smoking socialist,
it's playing on his own,
sort of like public awareness.
So I think Barack Barack Obama's isn't
an excellent politician and he states
mentally and humorous in a way that
doesn't diminish the state is I would
say Boris Johnson.
He sort of pays a kind of an ethical
price,
vichy mode that's just more perhaps more
to do political stance.
I think sometimes,
and I,
I'm,
I could be being unfair here,
but the Nigel Farrage joke though was
basically a not funny,
not funny,
isn't funny.
You know,
we've,
you know,
people love audience.
Laughter is highly sophisticated.
I don't need to tell you this,
but people will laugh.
People laughing as they do in
conversations to show that they approve
or they agree or they understand or they
remember or they've noticed something,
you know,
as much as it is to do with the
movement,
and I'm definitely not saying it's not
amusement,
but the knowledge of project was a kind
of like a here is that in in the same
way people up until recently used to
produce it and there's Donald Trump in
itself is a punchline and larger.
Just a punchline.
Whereas the Obama joke and I fully
accepted may well have been written for
him,
his self depreciating and slightly more
complex in terms of the structure of a
joke.
It's not just a,
here's a funny thing.
Will laugh at that.
I may be biased by as we all are,
when we're appraising humor about
personal feelings here and that's it,
but I'm interested in Obama because in a
vocally he just,
he's,
he's articulate and he used his rhetoric
beautifully.
He's a beautiful speaker and he's April
of capable of dropping into humor at the
right time,
in the right way,
in a way that it's done well.
So he kind of excels in how it uses his
voice and he's made humor.
Part of that.
Although one of the things,
the things
he was also doing in that drug and this
not stupid perhaps to do with your area
of or certainly not mine,
but like he's also diminishing the
seriousness of Bernie Sanders,
which I imagine the point that you made
the point that I don't know when that
speech was happening,
but clearly it was the point when they
were undetermined on who would be the
candidate.
Hillary Clinton or Bernie Sanders.
And it's interesting that sanders is at
that point used as the punchline of a
joke.
So like,
I think that I'm very interested in the
relationship between comedy and power
and I'm very interested as someone who's
been ridiculed for entering the public
political sphere out of a comedic
background.
How actually in reality the people in
power often used comedy and humor to get
what they want and to create the kind of
impressions that they want.
Should we have a listen to Nigel farrage
being funny now because he's,
he's another politician that sort of,
I think,
you know,
like you can't sort of whether or not
you agree with people's politics,
is there the power of their tree and
that their ability to have an impact.
Is that something that sort of,
you know,
even in humor is something that we have
to take seriously and then we've got the
prime minister
or should I call him in this context?
Piggy in the middle.
Oh,
that's a good joke.
Now obviously that's a joke that he's
doing that when David Cameron,
as we know that the former prime
minister put his genitals into a pig's
mouth.
That's just the prime minister of a
country putting his genitals in the
mouth of a dead pig there.
Um,
so like,
um,
like,
ah,
for Raj,
I think he's an interesting case because
one of the things that humans being used
for in all of these cases is,
I'm like,
you,
we're like one another.
I'm not on the other side of some chasm
of puppeteering you and using power.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's a sort of,
some element of sharing their people
won't.
If people don't agree with you or don't
like you,
they won't laugh,
you know?
It's um,
yeah,
I hate that that's happened to me before
and it's,
it's certainly,
uh,
you know,
I can think of comedians obviously,
not you,
but I can think of comedians that I
would never see something about them.
I don't like them and I'm,
I can't imagine what they'd have to do
to make me laugh.
Now that's just me making it place.
Literally,
literally nothing to do with them
entirely to do with my biases,
but it will affect my behavior around
them.
So I can appreciate,
you know,
with frauds,
I can recognize the structure of that
joke and how well it's gone down,
but I'm still not smiling because,
you know,
again,
like voices.
It's about who I want to be.
I don't want to be part of that human.
I don't want to be sharing that.
But you're right,
there's a strong element of sharing and
agreement.
Yes.
That's how it's being used.
I mean,
because even the word communicator means
creator of community creating
allegiances.
You're communicating.
We're not one.
We are many that are bonded and I see
Alan Moore that are graphic artists
saying that,
you know,
they use like spelling,
but we spell that there's a magic in
words.
You can create feelings in another
person through what you say.
I think that this is a powerful and
appealing idea to me.
Um,
and at this time I suppose it's sort of
a pact.
Is it a postmodern phenomena?
I know I'm not qualified to say,
but we're sort of seeing an emergence of
a different type of politician and that
its apex I think is Donald Trump.
And I'd like to talk about him and his
use of humor and his ability to
communicate because this is a thing that
is sort of difficult to say,
but I'll ask anyway.
So I'm,
I kind of like,
I mean,
he's personally attacked me,
like,
you know,
like literally I've got,
we use it in my standup show,
rebirth.
There's like huge.
Like there's a bit of him guard Russell
Brand Byron Idiot.
I really like naming me and attacking
me.
But before he was president actually.
But that's,
you know.
But um,
it's kind of what I like about Donald
trump is a sentence that's not easy to
finish,
is that he's kind of,
he's kind of certainty.
And like there's something I think quite
likable sort of shrugging.
He always seems like he's shrugging off
and I find it sort of interesting when
things are so,
so because I suppose my particular take
on politics is that there's a lot of
concealment,
a lack of transparency.
Someone like Donald Trump,
I sort of think,
well,
there's a plainness of bovine
obviousness.
I'm rather enjoying that things are
being revealed that shouldn't be.
And things are being concealed.
That shouldn't be like the top of his
head.
There's,
have a,
let's have a listen to.
Um,
I just have a listen to Donald Trump
saying saying,
you've got it there.
Django Hillary
accidentally bumped into me and she very
civilly said,
pardon me,
this is the first time ever,
ever that Hillary is sitting down and
speaking to major corporate leaders and
not getting paid for it.
The media is even more bias this year
than ever before.
However,
Michelle Obama gives a speech and
everyone loves it.
It's fantastic.
They think she's absolutely great.
My wife,
Melania gives the exact same.
That's actually a good job.
That's the best joke because he's the
victim of it.
That is so self effacing.
I mean,
NASA.
Gosh,
that's dangerous.
Now this has been an argument like the
second one was obviously in front of
Hillary Clinton.
He criticized there again accurately.
And you can say,
of course,
like,
you know,
communicative skills become more
important in a time when there's a lack
of trust.
Uh,
talking about people generally speaking,
feel like the politics doesn't serve
them,
that democracy doesn't serve them.
If someone turns up that's kind of
applicable or appealing in a way that's
surprising.
Hey,
so it has a particular impact.
What was there?
What did you think about that?
He's certainly has.
He has quite a strange voice because he
doesn't do a lot of the things that
people kind of get pushed towards in a
liquor.
Certainly for British and I know that
has to be a provider that obviously I
don't understand American accents in the
same way,
but it doesn't sound communication.
It doesn't sound like he's given them
any insight into perhaps don't do that
strange high pitched thing when you're
going for a job,
but you know he's because he's got a
high pitched voice and he sounded,
you know,
it's not.
It's a bit nicer with there some
restriction going on in there and it's
kind of,
I can't do it,
but they're there.
It's got a quite a,
quite a limited range of 30.
He doesn't.
What does that mean?
The music of your voice and we go in and
out of fashion is unlocking that.
If you remember back to when Neil
Kinnock did that amazing speech about
militant and the grotesque chaos will
leave.
It comes a little lever counseling.
It's just a beautiful piece of music.
It's just,
it's an amazing speech,
but the,
the,
the music of his voice is absolutely
extraordinary.
Is furious,
absolutely furious.
And that's gone largely out of fashion.
You don't find in u k political rhetoric
that that kind of use and the voice in
that way because it sounds hysterical.
I bet it doesn't sound managed or
managerial bureaucratically.
Like one of the things that came in with
Tony Blair and actually Debbie Cameron
fully did this as well,
was that kind of like,
well,
we're just having a chat sort of
quality.
I'm talking to you now.
This is because you can trust me.
It is new labor.
Look,
I'm just actually just saying stuff
like.
Yeah,
I know what you mean.
There was sort of,
it was my friend Adam Curtis says that
it was like,
you know,
like sort of Clinton and Blair was
heralding of a sort of a managerial type
of politics.
We're just managers.
What we are,
we like middle managers at work.
You don't.
We're not sort of powerful demagogues.
We're not sort of people that are would
like them.
It's not like an outfit that punching
above his weight there from the podium
fishing the skies and roaring like as
people just meekly giving you data and
quite an affable way now like Tony Blair
continues to grow ever more presidential
while damning his own party.
But at that point it was like there was
a kind of an unaccessible ordinariness
to him.
Exactly.
And and it was obviously it's conveyed
in many ways,
but it was really big part of how he
spoke.
I'm aware that there's that phrase isn't
there to,
to a man with a hammer,
everything looks like a nail and I bring
everything down to voices except there's
other stuff going on.
But in that,
in that context you can even sort of
seeing Obama was returning,
it had elements of a more kind of a
classical rhetoric in his style and the
way he uses voice and your point to make
here.
I imagine that he was afforded a
different kind of exoticism because the
narrative that is present presidency was
African American and there's always an
American politics.
The idea that that is an inclusion from
outside of the mainstream.
Using that to inflate the idea that the
popular mainstream is ethical look after
all,
we've got an African American president
and I suppose as if he had a different
type of vocal license.
I don't know about different kinds of
political license because there are sort
of different constraints.
We're talking about a particular issue,
but it's interesting that you had more.
What was that word again?
Oh,
he's just got a bit rhetorical.
President used the music of his voice
quite a lot,
but I suppose it was also
interesting.
I'm Deborah Cameron's done some work on
this woman from Oxford University
professor at Oxford University and she's
described.
Have you looked at.
Come on.
If you look at a gang culture and you
get a very particular linguistic use for
them,
gangs,
people use that to mark their
membership.
If you look at female members of gangs
in the US,
they will very often be the most kind of
like classic users of the slang because
there might be other stuff they can't
get involved in,
but they can get the words right and
it's marking your,
I deserve to be here because I'm doing
this right.
And maybe if Obama had been less formal
in his speech,
people would be more like,
oh,
well I'll just can't do this at all.
You know,
um,
you know,
it was marking I deserve to be here and
I can damn well you into this was
perhaps held to a higher standard.
But you're saying they're very,
my voice now.
It's killing me as you can hear what
you're saying.
Like Donald Trump sounds a little bit
strangulated and sort of,
I mean his voice.
In fact,
sap,
like he very much positioned himself as
I'm going into.
I'm draining the swamp.
Every said I'm going to go there.
I'm going to mix stuff up.
And he,
even on a vocal quality like the voice
is interesting isn't because the voice
in some ways is a ghost in the machine,
is the vibration of the vocal cords.
It isn't actually there at all.
Your Voice,
your inhabited by this thing.
So isn't there something essential about
voice?
This is part of your,
excuse me,
essence who you are or vocalist who you
are at your core or your soul or
something.
It is.
There's a real truthiness devices.
Um,
if I,
when I got here,
I was nervous and I was aware when I was
supposed picking to jen and when I first
met you,
I could hear the tension in my voice
because it absolutely you can't get with
very hard to get past it.
It must be crippling to know that much
about vocal communication and then to
still be subject to rules that are
beyond that kind of regulation.
And I'll know what the hell is this
adrenaline doing?
Some of vocal folds.
But it's um,
and,
and that's just true.
So if you are in an emotional state,
it affects your body and your voice is
being made by your body.
It sounds stupid,
but if I don't use my voice,
you won't know anything about what I
sound like.
I have to do something.
It's an action as much as it is
language,
the voice.
So it's uh,
it's,
you can get information from my facebook
photo.
If I was asleep,
I was dead.
My face doesn't need to do things for
you to take a picture of you when you're
dead.
This has gone very much.
I'll be in touch with the coroner was
really silent witness,
but you,
you,
you have to do something for a voice to
be there.
And that's why it is.
You say it's this weird ephemeral thing
and it's very,
so much and it's so.
And it can be an incredibly strong tell
to your emotional state and while it can
be very hard to work around so because
it was what it can,
what it can do to your body.
It's revealing.
So the more sort of masking techniques
and manipulative techniques that you can
get into it,
the better,
but I suppose the,
all of the,
in a way that is hard to hold up an
absolute standard because
like in other areas,
Barack Bama is being judged in a
different way to Donald Trump.
Nigel farrage,
he's being charged in a different way.
It's,
it's reasonable to make Theresa May,
I think,
a bloody horrible voice.
Three to my haven't being funny,
but there's no sort of gargly,
Strangley,
post-coital sort of warble oh,
there's something in there.
I don't like much.
What is it?
I think um,
it's very immediate.
It's very hard to judge voices outside
of everything else you know about
somebody so that,
that's,
that's a difficult part.
What you're saying isn't evil voice.
He's got that kind of cracked bell
quality.
Like there's a.
I feel like she's striving to do
something with a voice that she's not
quite landing on and that's not.
But she's having them lessons.
You know,
when people get really famous that they
go,
you're going to stop talking about that
mate,
your prime minister now.
It's really interesting.
I'm listening to Margaret Thatcher now
because she was told,
expressly told you,
speak to women,
speak with pitch to two eyes,
speak lower men with men won't take you
seriously,
and when you listen to an hour,
all you can hear is the effort.
She's taking a voice down to somewhere
where she probably didn't really want to
be.
And that's the majority of the argument.
You hear the falseness for like that
sort of.
I'm down here,
I can't even catch the lowdown as the,
she again,
she,
I didn't remember that.
So these things.
So the very fact that so much effort
expended on it means that it is a real
thing.
It's a huge factor.
I can think of,
um,
you know,
significant politicians in the past few
years who've been largely undone by
aspects that people have heard in their
voice and that they haven't been able to
work around.
Well,
ed miliband would be an example of
somebody that seems like it sounds a
bit.
What was it,
Buddy Hill?
Oh,
they'll go.
Both.
Just filled it out.
My buttons quite nasal quality to his
voice and quite um,
it,
it sounded like it was difficult for him
to speak.
No.
Normally he sounded scared of his voice.
That's think something that was said to
be sounding voice.
So I've worked with someone.
Listen,
he sounded like someone who kind of knew
that people were going to be critical of
his voice when he started talking.
I Sat,
it does not,
it's not an election for not giving me a
bit of fun.
Well,
I am.
I've worked with a performance poet who
actually has a very similar voice to ed
miliband and he does poetry out,
you know,
he's out on the streets doing poetry and
never,
never because it was a bit nasally.
I don't think people are enjoying this
because he's just,
I'm doing my thing and I really wished
they'd bill banker just love his voice
and forget about what people might say
about it because actually it was him,
sandy anxious about his voice.
His seat was often the thing you were
picking up on,
like how you lose losing erection if you
think about it too much.
Sorry.
I said that now,
like now could we have listened to
theresa and then
Jeremy Corbyn's see if we can judge
their voices here that are in
parliament.
We are going to hear Theresa May's
Voice,
which Sophie Scott was already said she
disliked.
What?
Did she support the reopening of
Wellingborough prison some program or
would you rather just sing happy
birthday and I'm very happy to wish him
a very copy the estate today.
Many happy returns.
I hope that Mrs Bowen is going to treat
the occasion inappropriate manner in the
sex club,
a sex
quip.
So for Scott there is some.
I mean it feels unfair to which those
people's voices,
because we've kind of got what we've got
and we're criticizing someone's foot,
but it's that there is a source of like
a foot mouth won't shoes that were too
tight.
I can't tell you exactly what's
happening,
but there's something going on that a
couple of points in the evening that
joke where she lucky tent sound in a
vocal folds is giving a weird sort of
all.
It's a lot.
I can't do an impersonation of it and
Widdecombe does it a lot.
It's got a posh word speaking.
You think that.
Alright,
so we've caught all of this stuff.
There's obviously a neurological
component until after we have discussed
this,
but there's an anatomical component of
course to voice it says something that's
happening at the level of the vocal
chords and you think that sometimes
there's a little strangulated how you
hold at.
Well,
you know,
bearing in mind everything about your
voice is reflecting a lot of complex
stuff about you,
but actually it's diff.
Big differences do come in and how you
use your,
your larynx,
your vocal folds.
So,
um,
that's coming in in terms of just what
have you got.
So men have larger vocal folds that are
thicker,
so just like a larger musical
instrument,
they make a lower sound.
And I'm the French horn.
The producer of this show plays French
horn.
So I just gave me a little look then
because I knew we'd be thinking about.
But even then if you,
um,
if you hold your vocal fold slightly
differently.
So I,
I'm right now doing something called
modal voice and they just,
you know,
that's how,
that's how I know using tricks,
how I am vibrating,
the vocal folds.
So all you do to vibrate them as you
bring them together and then you're,
you're,
you're using your chest actually to
produce a very finally controlled flow
of air out.
So they fly back and forth and make it
sound.
Just like Gareth playing.
He's French horn when he's doing the
same thing at his lips.
That's where you really can play.
So you've got this,
you've got this musical sound here,
but in fact even if you hold them under
slightly different tension and I'm not,
now I'm doing something cool,
creaky voice voice and it's,
it's actually holding the vocal folds in
a slightly slack away.
So they vibrate differently and you get
this,
you get some soda,
sounds a bit more laid back to us
actually.
Although they porsche wave speaking
David Cameron and incredibly creaky
voice.
That's that.
And it's a massive part of American
accents.
So it's actually one of the main one,
the main place where you'll find creaky
voice
of my voice.
Right here I am.
This is me just talking.
Now.
I'm trying not to be self conscious.
I'm trying to be a normal man.
I have got a little bit water caught on
the Tom and Jerry Punch.
Whatever.
You just get that.
If you know Tom and Jerry Punch bag
proper.
According the Tom and Jerry a punch bag,
you have a very interesting voice
because you really do use melody a great
deal and you're obviously you don't.
I'm new here.
Comes in,
comes the scientist to tell you that you
also speak quite quickly,
actually combines to give quite a
pleasant way.
Christ on Mount Sinai.
It would've been good at talking one
day.
Jesus.
He must have been hearing from us well
into it.
Let's face it,
it caught on.
There's actually something really
central about humans standing up and
talking and people or doing things with
their voices.
People like watching it.
We like watching somebody speak with
skill.
We like watching somebody saying,
we love watching somebody big box.
We're like watching actors.
We,
we actually,
there's something really entrancing
about the performance of the voice.
What'd you think about Hitler then?
Not as policies.
There's face it now we can say that he
was a cruel man,
like he's vocal style.
Putting that to one side moment for
crimes.
He seems to have been a very engaging
public speaker.
There's a wonderful quentin crisp quote
satellite.
Someone asked him,
why did Hitler have charisma and credit?
Crispin said,
well,
I suppose he must have done otherwise.
You wouldn't have an awful lot of people
now have a certain age wandering around
Germany saying,
well,
I really don't know what came over me.
So he was obviously able to.
Yeah,
create the same man.
Quentin crisp offered this definition of
charisma.
The ability to influence without logic.
Yes.
An interesting definition of that.
So like,
because like when I watched hit lab,
we're trying to do for science against
Hitler obviously,
but I think,
I don't know if I'd like someone going
on like that at me.
He's really ranting and raving.
He seldom mellow.
Well I think it's,
suppose you just get these big fashions
as well.
So we've seen it recently in politics,
big changes in what we think sounds like
appropriate.
You just don't get Neil Kinnock style
rhetoric in government now for us here,
we've moved very quickly through that
and you,
you get these big changes and even see
it in acting.
If you go back,
you know,
over the last century styles and what
looked like naturalistic acting change a
lot.
So what we want to see in a talker can
be highly variable.
If you get that in and everything,
it's what humans do,
what we are cultures learn and develop
and change.
We don't tend to sit with just one thing
going,
this is the best it will ever be.
What are the external factors that are
changing?
Something as seemingly fundamental is
natural,
but you know,
like this is what is natural with
natural alters.
Because natural means essential.
Natural means without inflection.
Natural means absolute and total.
And if that changes as a result of
acculturation,
what is being expressed?
And one of the reasons I'm interested in
voice,
you know,
to share that shit with Juliet says in
Romeo,
Juliet,
like voice,
voice,
be breath and breath be life.
But it's like it's something about
essence.
And like in the beginning there was the
word or the vibration,
and I've heard these interesting sound
from deep space.
It sounds like gongs vibrating
into the infinite,
that there is something like in the way
that we communicate that is connected to
truth very,
very deeply.
And if this is something that can be
manipulated and managed and used,
his power could potentially be
limitless.
Well,
it can be.
And you can certainly think of examples
where we get caught up in this element
of performance.
I suppose one thing is true,
it's all a performance.
Me Talking to you now,
I am performing being so fee.
There's never a,
some abstract notion of uh,
sophie voice.
There's always been doing it for someone
somewhere in some particular context.
I'm never speaking without reference to
that.
And then there's the performance where
we as a group of people decide to shut
up and let some people worse than
onstage,
do something with their voices were we
then engage with that and what's
expressed in that changes.
So we know over a lifetime all of us
treat talk differently as we get older
because the people around us change how
they speak and we pick up on that.
Even the queen speaks differently to how
she used to speak her vows.
Shay,
now your majesty,
She's changed.
She's chopped it up a bit shallow and it
sounds,
it sounds like a continuous process of
everybody coming a bit less posh.
That's back to old dvds.
I even don't have to go back very far
like TB programs in the nineties.
You watched the news that everyone
sounds incredibly posh and they will
have sounded much less people in the
fucking sit down and tolerate this path.
Well,
I'll tell you what that is.
I do think whether I won't tell you
because you're an expert,
I'm just some bloke who's it for about
it for half an hour,
but what I reckon it is is that because
of mass communication,
we're all aware of broader context and
different variables and are able to make
different comparisons and now there's
sort of an emerging narrative that power
is corrupt and power is connected to,
I don't know,
poshness and elitist.
So there's a lot of myself,
my accent changes.
I'm terrible.
May Have bounced up and down that class
ladder like little trees,
football,
la.
Like when I'm the sort of around like
sort of like my girlfriend really
tormented me for a.
she's that how much I love working class
men.
Like when we went to think it was called
Drusen to pick up some gravel.
I'm sorry,
I'm so sorry that that's my life.
And there's this bloke there called mark
and he came over and wanted to fight ots
that and I was like a lot and I said
goodbye to him in an overly elaborate
way and even waved at him a second time.
I went back for another bite of a cherry
out the window,
but no,
actually I think I like that so I might
turn off,
but you don't need sand so that I might.
I taught our power how much sodium or
for power?
The tomatoes are bloody cockney
absolutely ridiculous.
What's going on with it.
That's exactly why we change our voices.
Interestingly,
the more we.
Let's again,
we have to change our voices to talk to
somebody so soon as we started talking
to each other without agreeing to do so,
we started to breathe together because
you have to do that to have a
conversation.
You have to coordinate how you breed
because that lets you time voices going
back and forth,
the turn taking conversation,
so physical.
It really is,
and we also matched
the pro,
the pitch and positive voices and the
rhythm of our voices.
We still have to bring together because
you've got this very rhythmic.
He's like,
he's like a dance conversation and you
can only do that dance if you start to
align your behavior so that has to
happen to talk,
and then the more you like someone,
the more you will start to do other
things,
to change your voice,
to bring it towards them.
So there are studies that have shown
that the more a man likes a woman will,
he will raise the pitch of his voice to
be near to hers just now.
Like everybody's super self conscious,
right,
and you believe that you'll start to use
the same words.
You start to use the same pronunciation,
jeep and start to use the same grammar
as each other and the and the more you
like the communication here.
That's the whole point of it is that
we're trying to make a connection with
one another.
We're trying to defy the material prison
of our anatomy.
You're feeling trapped and it's the
voice,
this thing that he's not really holy or
truly you,
but a vibration emanating from you that
is your misery that you've sent out in
the world to make connections and
communication with God.
I'm making this shit up,
God,
but it,
and it's always there,
so it's always expressing like a lot of
you that you don't realize and it's also
expressing how you feel about the people
that you're talking to fairly
unavoidably.
Oh No.
I'm going to start watching myself back
on the because we do a bit of funny bit
in my standup show,
right where I talk about when I did this
interview with Jeremy Paxman and one of
the things that we make jokes about,
I'm going by we.
I mean me because clearly I consider
myself for about nine people might
actually have people that work with her
in the room.
I'm like,
is that I love about how I go through
these different personas when dealing
with Jeremy Paxman,
they start very light and affable.
Then there's a moment where I got really
serious and then I get very sort of.
I like I started deliberately or not
deliberately,
but unconsciously referencing ethnic
speak rhythms,
very working class base because I
obviously see myself as speaking on
behalf of outsiders and I use it as an
attack technique.
It's very interesting to watch and your
marketing,
um,
because we can mark similarity with it.
You can mark difference because I get
right because I'm definitely not trying.
I didn't go good.
I knew I'd have to say.
I'm like,
no.
Listen brother.
I think it's absolutely ridiculous.
It's like a grime single,
but it's still playing that your apps,
your.
I was marking out your position to him
as clearly and how you're doing that.
What you're saying.
I'm not like,
you're not actively want to be you,
God.
I'm just telling myself.
Right.
So that's because I suppose the reason
that we wanted to talk to you,
Sophie Scott,
is for us to understand how.
Excuse me,
we can use these means of communication,
comedy,
laughter,
and vocal style,
but a,
Oh yeah,
this is good.
This is a better question than minuses
gas because like,
yeah,
this is,
it's more succinct way of saying what
vocal techniques should be aware of,
should we be aware of in the lead up to
the election from Theresa May,
Corbin and other
political leaders.
What should we watch out for?
There's very strong outbreak.
If people just going back to the same
phrase,
strong and stable,
rigging the election and just keep
saying and even with the same breath,
it's like they're just cutting and
pasting into the stream of speeches.
Why is this happening?
What's this?
There was the assumption,
I've got no attention span and we're
bloody idiot.
What's going on?
There is a fear.
It is.
I think there's very good evidence that
humans are not good at remembering
detail.
I remember just just remembering the
just you bloody idiot.
They think that's it.
I think they're trying to influence the
just and that just you let that just be
what it is.
When we met with surely creditors with
the ability to understand at least some
different words that mean strong and
stable,
you know,
rather than just repeat just exactly the
right and foreign and color,
but no just bombard people in to do if
people are beleaguered,
fearful and last the whole time.
If you just keep staying strong and
stable,
strong and stable,
who you're gonna vote for him starting
to roll out of order and if there's one
of the odd things about people using
lightheartedness or comedy in their
voice or in their approach,
particularly in politics,
it can play hard.
Well and it can also go horribly wrong,
you know,
but there is a exactly like you said,
right at the top,
there are situations where it's simply
inappropriate and people will sort of
recoil from it like that.
That wasn't right then there,
but in other situations it can be an
incredibly efficient way of looking
confident and able and like,
do you know what?
I can do this.
Yeah,
because what you're saying is I'm not
defined by this context,
but that is a risky game to say that I'm
outside of this context.
It's about power obviously,
isn't it?
Because if people say it's not
appropriate for you to say that in this
context by saying I'm in charge of the
context and if you say I disagree with
you,
then you're saying I'm in charge of the
context is a real game.
It is,
and I think sometimes one of the things
that we like about people who would be
prepared to use not necessarily like you
very rarely see somebody in politics or
just like all party all the time,
it just doesn't work,
but drops would drop into is
occasionally when it feels like,
or it could have gone a different way.
Now they've just sort of thrown a um,
something slightly lighter hearted
there.
That's kind of,
it's not just that,
oh well I'm in here for giggles,
but I'm kind of confident enough to let
you know that this is easy.
This is nothing to worry about.
I can do this.
And of course that might still be a bad
thing.
I'm not saying it's a signifier of
someone's good,
but it's certainly one of the things
that is sorely lacking.
I think at the moment people quite seem
quite frightened of what they're saying
and have going off message.
I think a climate of fear is what Jay is
prohibitive and restrictive.
I bet.
Fear literally affects us anatomically
and constricts the vocal cords and
socially it does that.
People are less likely,
you know,
like when when I do live shows now and
as I go out of metropolitan areas,
I think there's a nervousness when I
talk about Islam,
when I talk about like sort of subjects
that we've been taught to understand as
contentious and we therefore shouldn't
laugh from
them because I don't know what I'd be
looking like that agreeing with that,
where we go laugh though,
isn't it?
That's the,
that's where the communication becomes
valuable,
but what we include in what's humorous.
Now of course we won't be derisory
dismissive or cruel about things that
are important,
but I think humor precisely builds these
bonds as it does between a father and a
baby.
It does between whole communities
recognizing that ultimately with the
same.
I mean I've,
I might posit dear Professor Sophie,
that's what comedy is continually doing
is it's sort of,
it's shifting the frame and we say like,
Oh,
here we are.
You and I are having this conversation
making these podcasts and then comedy
says,
but we're going to die me.
See,
he's very,
very,
very temporary arrangement between us
and if we don't acknowledge the truth of
the fact that we can't hold this
together,
that there are powerful elements of not
only chaos of entropy and function that
are going to mean that everything's
going to end.
Things fall apart.
The center cannot hold and like I think
comedy is an expression that I'm all
right with that.
I'm okay with it and I think that like,
I use this a lot,
but like Tommy Cooper's act,
he said,
well,
the reason I think is beautiful is
because Tommy Cooper,
British comedian,
30 $40,
my God perhaps 50 years ago.
And like a lifestyle of that did a photo
magic act where things went wrong.
And I think the reason it's so
ingenious,
it's because it's like his intention is
like he's not even come on the stage to
try and be funny.
He's come out to try and do this magic
act and everything will be okay if only
this magic cat goes all right and the
magic act never does.
And that's where the intersection of
comedy happens there.
And if you look at sort of like musical
entertainers like Frankie Howard or
Kenneth Williams,
they always glancing to the side,
there's Harry,
he'll actually uses that sort of second
camera that he talks into sound that
there's another layer to reality,
that there's a connection.
I think between comedy and the trickster
and the trickster is forever saying this
isn't the absolute contexts.
There is another world.
There's another world.
And in the words of Morrissey,
there must be,
you know,
like.
So that's what I think is important
about comedy.
Do you now think I'm clever?
I'm like,
you're doing an man so as you must be,
but it's um,
the clearly extremely well put point.
Pay Them.
I,
we pay them to go.
It is very interesting.
If you look at the history of human
language,
and of course we were reliant on people
writing stuff down because words don't
stay around.
If you state them,
they've,
you look at wherever you find people
writing in human history,
you find them writing down jokes.
People have been making jokes as far
back as we can find written words.
They'd been writing graffiti on walls.
There's a piece of Babylonian Papaya us
with a really weak joke about how to
make a fair.
I go fishing.
Um,
you put naked women in fishing nets and
maybe it works better in India,
in ancient Egypt.
Maybe there's a pun in there.
In ancient Egyptian,
they think,
well there's on its own is not enough.
Put Women in fishing nets.
Drill fire could come into the pyramid.
No,
you probably can't get out of here.
There's a whole
Roman book called the laughter lover,
which is,
it's preserved all the jokes and it is
interesting because they have the
structure and appearance.
The jokes,
they're not funny.
Jim Bowman actually did an act where he
read out from it and he had to do a lot
of work,
a lot of work and it's because of course
the,
the content changes.
And I think a lot of the times science
when it tries to look at comedy,
gets caught up on that because you can't
find something that's always funny for
everybody everywhere.
That one glance at that.
But by the Babylonian joke that somebody
that was so good,
they wrote it down,
um,
suggest that,
but you don't want to forget this thing.
Go and get mashups of paper.
It's probably a complicated.
And then so you've got this.
But the point is that people were doing
it.
We have used humor probably from as soon
as we had words,
we were laughing before we had words and
we will probably using words to try and
get to laughed and maybe in a playful
way or whatever way since then.
But then you get this very interesting
development as an art form because you
see this in humans,
you know,
endlessly endlessly innovating and
producing stuff that doesn't immediately
kind of necessarily get you fed or keeps
you somewhere to sleep.
But which is fun and interesting and
engaging.
When you see the modern humans may
emerge.
You just get this explosion of stuff and
comedy,
I think a huge one of those things.
And you start to get the role of the
person that you say,
the trickster,
the person who's the jester,
the person who has the role of kind of
controlling that.
And it's a very,
very interesting evolution.
It's worth bearing in mind that standup
comedy is incredibly new art form.
The only really existed as we would
recognize it with,
you know,
some one person on stage talking to the
audience since a really unfortunate man
called Frank Fay.
He was around,
he was around sort of in the twenties
and thirties,
but he was the first guy who had the
sort of hotspur to not have another
person on stage with him.
Exactly.
So it was to never feed and he didn't
have comedy costumes and he didn't.
He kind of came on stage not going blog
and I'm not putting anything on.
And they had this kind of like,
it's easy to find some flexible youtube
because it's very.
It doesn't look like I'm not the
strongest material,
but it absolutely slayed.
And he had this kind of confidence to do
this and it was.
That was part of you consider themselves
to be a lot better than the other
comedians must have done because they
just have the balls to go up.
They June no more light to the feed guy.
Phil incarcerate must've been
magnificent.
We're lucky charms,
comedy politics.
Well actually also choose politics and
the reason why it's not.
Oh Frankie,
he's not more frequently discussed the.
He was a massive Nazi maps upside with
Franklin,
so very good.
This guy,
hold on a second.
This slaughter all non Christian people
killed the Gypsies about him,
right?
Yeah.
No,
frank.
I'm not going to fly.
You're going to need to get advocates.
He used to work with.
I won't work with fitbit.
They bought.
Why not have them all?
Oh Frank.
Horrible Nazi.
He was running pro Hitler rallies in New
York after police.
Pretty much people who felt that was
done and dusted.
The this Hitler Fella.
Hey,
bad tool band checked your fucking face.
So he's largely not remembered fondly.
Really.
I'll see frank better commemorate it.
Bev,
you look at Bob Hope.
You can see Bob Hope's act.
He was completely influenced by his
voice and sort of the appearance and
that kind of sophisticated gentlemen act
law.
What's the great master?
So you can see the roots of it there.
So they think that that hat on you can
sort of see stand up comedy is being
another manifestation in our culture of
this endless drive for humor,
for comedy and we're still,
I think negotiating the role of what
that means.
What's this discussion about like the
written word versus or a tree because
like I've heard that like there's some
people like this in America.
He calls himself American Indian
actually,
sadly deceased called Russell me.
It's like that.
He says there's this beautiful speech
which I read written down,
but it begins.
Lastly you,
yeah,
you may very well be reading this,
but I'm speaking [inaudible] European
people.
One of the things you've given us is the
written word will.
Ours is an oral tradition and we believe
in the truth of speech and the parents,
which they never had to have a thing
about socrates saying that it was sort
of more important the spoken word and
the written word because there isn't a
central truth that can only.
I supposed to relate to the voice and
the presence.
What does this all mean?
Well,
I think that's exactly because there's
the person there.
You've got that you're reacting to more
than just the words they're saying and
you can't not.
You're making assumptions about that
person.
If you couldn't see me,
you would probably have an idea of what
I looked like based on what I sound
like.
They could be utterly wrong,
but we do that all the time.
We're always trying to work out who
people are,
where they're from,
all this.
At the same time as they're talking to
us,
we're adding in all this other stuff
about who we think they must be based on
what they sound like and it gives a
power and an interpretation than
sometimes the truth to voices that I
think does give it a different kind of
waste and the written word is amazing,
but you can see and you look at people
trying to write texts or emails or the
way they try and put stuff back in to
kind of try and give their character
their the emojis or dancing.
The emergence of emojis is because of
the limitations of the spoken word.
I mean,
you remember how it used to be like
there was too many problems around like
miscommunication around text and email
and like it was forever happening.
We made.
I was upsetting people unlike when I'm
on radio,
I steak right out.
I travel.
No,
no,
that was funny.
Come on.
Do you know what I meant?
Smiley face.
Apology face.
I'm like,
but like sort of.
I can see that.
Yes.
There's a level of sophistication that
the written word can't deliver
and perhaps in the pans of proust and
there are other you.
So the written word,
you can sit there and do some sorts of
compositional work on it before you
deliver it to the world.
You know,
when you start talking you've got to
keep going.
I launched on a sentence and I'm somehow
got the make my way to the end of it.
Frank fry weren't a racist.
Oh it is this sky and bloody well and
another thing that this threat chat chat
now,
but he wasn't like that.
He was more of a smarmy character.
It was fairly unpleasant.
Can't be a Nazi.
Gone mostly say a cow.
Oh yeah.
We had this thing,
professors sophie,
that a aint helpin the satire satirizing
trump,
that it makes him more cozy and likable,
ineffable somehow,
and it's just not a monster vacation.
It's sort of affable.
I think it is sometimes the case that we
can mistake laughing at somebody for
being like the end of the critical work
we need to do and it was associated with
them.
So it is really interesting that,
uh,
it was it John Oliver a couple of years
ago was going,
oh,
please run for presidency is going to be
so funny.
And it was funny.
There were some amazing and it was also
actually happening.
And then it's actually company.
It's funny now I'm still trying to keep
it humorous flap just by looking at it
as if it's not real,
but it is real,
isn't it?
Yeah.
This is actually happening as far as we
know,
it's actually there and that's now,
you know,
you can make.
It's interesting to see how people make
very good at making jokes at the stuff
around I'm a trump,
you know,
all that.
Sean Spicer stuff that they're doing so
well on snl.
It's harder because it's already absurd
and point,
you know,
we were already made all the jokes they
were to make about him before he became
president and it seems that it's almost
like a limit to how far we can go with
it.
If you look at,
you know,
popular sites like the onion.
I'm not there making funny jokes but
actually not landing on trump because
maybe that's already we're already too
far into it to be able to have any
distance enough to make jokes about it
or maybe it's just that it doesn't
matter.
You know,
if you're making jokes,
you're still talking about him and he's
still winning.
Evidently there was a degree of
sophistication to that campaign that
obviously this of popular press we're
not aware of and I think it's sort of
like more as well as communicative.
It was statistical.
I think they understood that these
people in this area want this message.
Give them that message no matter what
the people over there think they're
never gonna vote for you anyway.
Forget them.
I mean you can sort of see as well,
so communicate the relationship between
communication and truth versus
authenticity.
Like,
you know,
like the white sort of politics has
changed in that it seems to be this
peculiar.
It's dance or manipulation of power now.
It's notable.
I think that there's a sort of now kind
of redundancy to Ukip.
You kind of think ukip done its job.
The Conservative Party is you kip now,
so it doesn't really,
you don't really require one for Raj has
so disappeared like an of a tenor to.
It's interesting that I would use that
kind of a vocal or word not just to
impress you,
but also because it seems right that
there's,
there is this something tonally about
the conservative party that seems to be
acknowledging exclusion that the anti
immigration rhetoric,
this vague xenophobia and of course the
removal from the European Union itself.
It's present,
it's present now politically.
There's doesn't seem to be any need for
it now for Ukip.
I mean primarily I entirely agree.
It's,
um,
it's been an interesting cycle to watch
it happen and there was something
similar happened in the seventies,
but the really far right organizations
which were essentially expressly
incorporated into Margaret Thatcher's
version of conservatism and we've seen
an nf and stuff.
Yeah,
the,
the British National Party that can do,
you know,
and they were pretty full on and there
was kind of an extension of what the
Conservative Party roughtly colored as a
remit that just started,
just incorporate it.
And they did indeed go away,
is gangs of skinheads at rallies,
but they then became the government got
rid of those gangs of skin edge around.
It's almost like God,
the government now still agreeing with
it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's very interesting.
Sophie.
Sixteen minutes.
We've done.
This has already been longer than I
anticipated.
I really enjoyed the analysis of the
politicians.
I liked the role of laughter.
Should we try and find something
optimistic to end upon?
I mean if laughter and Kim and
communication and it's ultimately about
creating a community,
then perhaps they will always be.
There has to be a role for or
authenticity doesn't there.
There has to be a way that we can
communicate those central truths and it
will bring people together.
They aren't or can't be.
This reductive,
repetitive,
simplistic,
disingenuous politics that's come to
govern our time.
This kind of casual,
halfhearted,
almost nihilism of,
uh,
of the trump presidency,
the madness of the lurch to the right
across the world.
Is there another way?
I mean,
I.
something that you've kept talking about
in your,
that was really badly put.
Was it something you kept talking about?
You keep coming back to love and I think
there's,
I think we haven't been very good at
recognizing the importance of law.
You shouldn't be embarrassed about that.
Why?
So That's interesting.
There's been removed from the,
from the centric the bay.
We've been told like don't talk about
love is stupid.
It's childish.
I mean this attack on Jeremy Corbyn,
Martin headed by Boris Johnson were
saying stuff like that.
You know,
if you're at eaton saying things like
that probably gets you to the top.
Probably get first dibs on the facts if
you can come up with a little lyric like
that.
But like saying that,
oh,
he's too compassionate,
he's too kind.
He wouldn't nuke people willy nilly.
It's not saying that there's no room for
love or compassion or connection like
that.
These things are sort of,
they have no place in the,
in power,
uh,
but they,
they're central to our lives.
So here's an example that all the
evidence
now seems to suggest that losing your
hearing in adulthood is a significant
risk for dementia.
Whoa.
Recap.
And it's a significant risk.
Why?
Pay attention to how loud headphones on
when you're listening to music.
But it's,
um,
it's interesting because it doesn't seem
to be because it's happening to the same
mechanism.
It's not the same thing that's affecting
your ears as affecting your brain.
It seems to be because losing your
hearing and not necessarily getting
access to ways of restoring that takes
you out of social interaction,
disconnect and you go mad and you wear
your brain does not work as well.
Everything that we know about human
brains say they evolve in interactions,
they develop in interactions.
Everything.
Your baby's learning about the world,
most of it she's learning and
interactions with you.
She got no pressure,
but that's the and it continues being
the case.
It's our main way of making,
maintaining social bonds,
remained talking to each other,
even in a world where you could do it
all we text,
we still go face to face,
we still talk to each other and that is
essential to our function as humans and
I think we are getting less and less
kind of,
um,
well even the reason that we don't seem
to be able to get this message across
the,
you know,
that the hearing loss is really risky
for you,
not just because it's a pain in the neck
to lose your hearing,
but it could really manifestly affect
the shape of your life.
We're not even taking that seriously as
a problem.
It's like,
yeah,
well that's one to watch out for them
and it's that.
It's the link,
the social link,
the human contact that that's actually
preventing that.
I think we start to need to acknowledge
more,
and I'm going to obviously I'm saying so
from a scientific perspective because I
think in science we tend not to take
these things seriously.
We study speech without ever considering
that we talk to each other,
we study emotions and never look at
laughter,
you know,
we just don't go in that direction very
often,
but I think it might be a wider part of
our debate about who we are as humans
because you know,
to be massively influenced by your
interview with Adam Curtis,
that the rise of individualism I think
sometimes takes the emphasis off what
we're doing to each other and more onto
us somehow powering through life on our
own towards death and actually it's not
trivial.
That's the contact we have with other
people is not a meaningless aspects.
That extra little bit of cheesecake in
our life.
It's.
It's actually essential to being a
human.
That's beautiful.
What a lovely way to end.
Professor Sophie Scott.
We must communicate.
We must connect.
There's more to life than being an
individual.
As a beautiful message.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for getting under the skin
with me.
Professor Sophie Scott.
Oh.